Hello, thisis Steve, the founder of Wealth Bank.
Steveshi learned 10 languages ​​through the method of raising mink. He
does
n't
teachyou one of the nearby mountains.
If you want to learn , you willfirst start
with the presidential election in the Spanish library. As
you
read, you will encounter countries youdid not know
about.
Or
you can click on the new intel and youcan
search for lions or add yourownbehaviors
.
You've created adirect linklimit like this
. It's
now blue and yellow. It's going to beblue andyellow.
In ,you have
tomake
a lot of winks. Make links not only for words youdon't know at all,but
alsofor all the countries you want to benefit from
.
You can do it.
Of course, whenyoulook at other lines, you canalso
review theyellow
ones youstudied
in advance.
If so, listen to it
every day
, reviewing a new one,
and through the process
you are doing you will become very fluent inthelanguage.
Ask the community questions
Maybe you'll get adecisionor you'll want to practice speaking
with the guitar
.
Then,without realizing it, you
'll become fluent in Spanish. Have
funstudying.